Now for this example we're going to
look at a function called ColorFromHex.
This function takes color represented
as an integer, specifically a UInt32 or
32 bit integer.
Now we're going to use hexidecimal
notation, because it's easier to read.
You may have seen colors represented
this way if you've worked in web
design before.
When a color's represented with six
hex digits, like this pink color here,
the first two hex digits represent
the red part of the color.
So this cc represents
The next two digit represent
the green part of the color.
And the last two digits represent
the blue part of the color.
So the ColorFromHex function is going to
use the bitwise & operator to isolate
each of these component parts.
It's going to isolate the red part,
the green part and the blue part.
That's what's happening with each
of these bitwise & operators here.
Then, with the shift operator,
it converts the R, G, and
B components into a number
that's between 0 and 255.
Finally, it divides the RGB components
by 255 so that the number is
fixed between 0 and 1, because that's
how a UI color is constructed.
If you had trouble following that,
then don't despair.
I've included a fun link, here,
to a video that really captures how red,
green, and blue values
are combined to create a color.
And if you look down here at the bottom
where we've called the function,
we've actually split out pink into
its red, green, and blue components.
And then we've printed out the colors
that combined to make this pink color.